[Music]
in this video i'd like to share with you
all a set of three exercises that work
on hand coordination specifically
switching the hands while keeping the
music the same each one is progressing
in difficulty by just a little bit so
the very first one is suitable for
beginners all levels before we get
started i'd like us first to get
familiar with just two chords
c major seventh and e flat major seven
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
aside from the harmony these exercises
all have two different parts the inside
and the outside parts
the first one
is just a broken triad
on the inside
so what you might want to do first is
just get used to alternating between the
hands left right
left
so on and so forth the outer part is
made up of single notes
just outlining the outside notes of the
major seventh chords
[Music]
and again just get used to alternating
between
the hands
from here i would suggest putting the
hands together in increments so first
maybe just playing major seventh chords
like so
[Music]
just switching
the hands between the lower three notes
and the upper note
[Music]
when that gets comfortable break up the
inner triad
[Music]
and then add in that lower note
[Music]
when you're playing this you may find
that it gets a little awkward when you
switch because you're not sure which
hand goes on top a general rule of thumb
whichever part has much more
distance to be traveled so in this case
the outer pitches
should go on top just so that you have
extra space around it and you're not
getting caught underneath for version
two here is the inside part
[Music]
and of course this gets repeated both
hands
this is the outside part
so like the first exercise
the outer notes of the major 7th chord
the thing to note about this version is
that i choose to switch the hands not at
the very beginnings of the groupings but
one note over so let me show you after
c major seven at e flat major seven here
instead of
hopping over to the c here
i just play that with the left hand
first
like so and then the c here
i switch over to my left hand
[Music]
this is where i like to switch the hands
you can really choose any point as long
as it's a little more deliberate and
you're planning for it for version three
if this is the pulse the inner part
[Music]
the outer notes for this one is slightly
different we're first playing the root
and the third of the c major seventh
chord
[Music]
and then the root and the ninth
[Music]
if you want to take any of these
exercises and take it up a notch try
switching the hands at different points
maybe after every repetition of the
chord or between the chords
or wherever else
[Music]
now here's a very very important tip
when you're practicing any of these
versions instead of focusing on the
actual switching of the hands which you
can just get from a few repetitions just
figure out where to switch that sort of
thing get it out of your head and focus
on what you're hearing
just focus on
hearing that repetition and
in a peaceful calm way
and let your hands figure out what to do
to maintain that continuity i hope that
helps i hope you found it interesting
and i'll see you very soon bye
you